the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
Jonathan send the email if you have
questions you still need a clarification
you send him but say we still expect you
do you decide to redo it you should do
it yourself they don't know discussions
you can go back and look at any books
but you do it yourself
ok any clarification unit okay so then
let's come back I spend this is the
chapter I spend the most time in terms
of per chapter so far we're really
talking about the transport law and the
content we talked is best applied to
ballistic transport meaning there's no
scattering you can still treat with
scattering but to say right now what are
we saying is if I want to know the
transport between any two points right
and now the transmittance so we learned
how to calculate transmittance of an
interface and how transmittance of film
multi near vacuums tunneling all those
in theory now you can at least say
you're not afraid of dealing with these
type of problems so if you know the
transmittance and they left flux
whatever flux here I'm doing the heat
flux so h-bar Omega is energy and so I'm
doing one to two months two to one but
at the end apply the principle of detail
balance which is essentially a second
law it says at the equilibrium the LED
flux must be zero and otherwise you
have creating imbalance it can go
spontaneously from form hot and cold
sites so that's not valid and that's the
principle dieter balance
so essentially you can say when we want
the cargo flux is the velocity
transmittance the quantity that the
transporter here is one mode right
quantum state and then the distribution
function difference the each state how
many particles we have either
corresponding temperature chemical
potential and Chris today energy so the
detailed balance really saved us from
calculating both sides because say you
can take any of these sides and do your
calculation as well as you know the
transmittance from that starting side to
the other side or other point and I
emphasize that at the end of last
lecture those kind of transport is a
high-low equilibrium so it's actually
hard to really define a quantity that
they were used to you in temperature
camera protein sure those are all
thermodynamic quantities and the example
we spent on the sometimes explained is
thermal boundary resistance when I have
acoustic wave comes toward the interface
on this side this is my in fact this is
my te one the corresponding distribution
of photons coming from this side and
reflect it and transmit it right and on
the other side I have the incoming with
a high risk a temperature a te to
reflected and transmitted so locally I
do not have at the interface on each
side of interface I do not have
equilibrium
and when I force my temperature
definition is this temperature the local
energy is not actually just a te one
Cara sticks but also transmission of te
to carry sticks so if you redefine a
local temperature or if you do charge
transfer a local tango potential your
lateral time your protein sure right
it's not the incoming one and you have
to recalculate that what's the local for
example if I want the first temperature
to be quivering the measure of a local
energy density I would define the local
temperature based on local energy
density that give me a different
temperature than this one
so those are highlighting Cronenberg
process I think the best way you
understand this is taking the
undergraduate problem of blackbody
radiation right if I have two black
surfaces and this is a t1 and this is a
t2 and now if you look at the inside
I have photons coming from one to two
and this has a carissa T of temperature
one and then I have photon going the
other side and have a Christic of
temperature to right and then I ask was
it a photon temperature you say there's
no you couldíve McCleary right you can't
define a photon temperature inside and
now you say okay i imagine i have a
detector with two phase both side is a
black also I have a small detector with
both sides a black and one side it
absorbs the temperature either from with
the temperature t1 the other side that
with the temperature t2 and you have a
uq number temperature here because of
the absorber thermalized right this two
temperature to to group our photons and
that temperature is a flat inside it's
because there's no change it depends on
going from one side to the other there's
no change so if you say okay my define
the photon conductance if I do
based on the photon temperature here at
the two sides you know there's no the
other t and you're conducting the
infinite but if I define based on the
temperature of the solid I can measure
this easily I don't have that detector
right but I can define if I'm putting my
several couple to measure two solid
surfaces so the solid object the
blackbody a measure t1 a measure t2 my
thermocouple is not measuring the photon
temperature my thermocouple is measuring
the solid temperature in fact my thermal
how is measuring the full-on temperature
so you're actually fool in this case
right but that's what are you in your
engineering calculation that's the
definition you'll be using so this is
the temperature you'll be using you're
using the solid temperature you so I
give another example where say people
measure the conductance of a wire
electric conductance right
they put a two metal probe for example
you do a carbon nanotube right you put a
two big electrode you measure voltage
here that's like a you measure in these
two solid temperature you can't measure
the electron chemical potential exactly
at the contact you don't have what they
prove that usually measure that low core
voltage if you measure that local
voltage again the electron in the
ballistic regime there's no voltage drop
you should get an infinite conductance
okay so this definition dependent when
you do your experiment you need to know
what they are comparing to don't compare
orange with apples okay so with this
basically you can
really if you do nano scale transport
this could be a foundation to understand
a lot of papers in literature people
starting different kind of nano scale
transport problems right we talked about
conductance and many other examples so
just to take the carbon nanotube right
and if you write down let us see the you
nitric conductivity so there is this
Universal conductance and turns out that
that Universal conductance for one
dimensional object it doesn't depend on
the material and the conductance G per
mole per quantum channel column stage
right is e square H bar nature what are
there the factor 2 now you see square PI
H bar right so if you substitute the
lumber this conductance or equivalent
resistance which is universe of the
conductance is the one to two 6500k so
through each channel you add another
channel you have two parallel channel
the conductance doubles resistance
reduced by half right the quantum states
so people have in the past and measure
in fact there was the experiment are
doing say various quantum transport a
particle at low temperatures and this is
electrical and you can do a thermal
right if I have two temperature
difference between two points and the
thermal conductance for one dimensional
object is PI maybe
t ok B Square t and divided by six H bar
okay and this one so it's not this is a
again Universal because it doesn't have
a mature property there right and if you
plug in your Lemberg conductance here I
get about this is ten to the twelve
times T and the watt meter square Kelvin
so this lumber will be interesting for
some of my students doing the interface
resistance right it's a the yeah we know
they oh this is a positive troll no1 let
me see negative twelve wait I have some
number problem pi K BT square k bt 46 10
to the minus 12 tee and what meter
square so the no I think I have a
similar I have to check this number
doesn't look right because G typically
isn't in the lines this is minus 12 so
maybe I'll check okay I don't know where
it is wrong now okay so that's the
universal conductance and if we do for
example we do in the airfield I have two
plates right and I have typically the
wave comes in and has a reflection and
has transmission right we say that when
the two surfaces are broader close by
you have autonomy phenomena and and the
again you with that you can calculate
transmittance and you do your
integration over all states you can get
the tongue the increased heat transfer
due to the tunneling or if you're
interested in charge electrical charge
terminating all those can be down low so
I think I'd say you'll be I encourage
you now you can look at literature
people study all this different essay
the nanostructure conducting surprise
sport and this is a very often discussed
what I have not finished is what's the
velocity internal internship this one is
actually a one that we asked at the
beginning how fast the particle really
travels right so let's discuss this
velocity group velocity and this is a
concept sometimes very hard to
appreciate to make to to understand what
is group velocity right so definition
wise it will be relatively easy but why
we see the group velocity is typically
when we use when we calculate that they
charge the heat that's the velocity I do
in my way reacts here for example why I
use group velocity so first say like let
me take a picture of a full-on
dispersion were in specifically the
ration I have K Omega and have
acoustical fall on one branch only I'm
looking at it and the group velocity is
a tangent of every point and that's the
group velocity and it's this velocity
velocity we use when we substitute it
into the I need transport that's a how
fast how much energy are say a fall and
will carry at that specific mouth
frequency right why I use that velocity
and first let's look at a wave because
I've been talking about clam leave
representation right so a wave that I
usually use either vector or scalar no
just write a simple scalar wave is a
must i omega t minus KX right I'm
assuming that K is in the extra ration
simple and this is a plan way of
representation I have right what's the
origin of my time was the end of the
time here for a to plan way that's minus
infinite to plus infant that's a true
plan way right there's no ending point
okay anytime I have an ending point I
don't just have one single frequency
there so example if I have a periodic
signal I can say this is omega zero but
only has a finite time span right let's
say T there T zero you only has a finite
time span and no mori you say okay I
have a periodic a signal but
mathematically that's not quite correct
right because this signal does not go
from minus infinity to plus infinity and
if I have here a signal over only
segment of time or lens I can do Fourier
series right so you can do your Fourier
analysis and you see the real frequency
of this wave is not a let us say they
hear the Omega zero is my fundamental
frequency of this wave right and then I
have Omega zero
I have home harmonics Omega zero will be
my heist vows and the to zero and so
write different of frequency around the
central frequency that's when I do the
Fourier analysis
okay so now because of this because in
solid or whatever there's never really
wave that goal from Madison firm to plus
infinite the generators for example the
atomic vibration the electron transition
from high energy to low energy the only
spare certain amount of time right all
the event only spent certain amount of
time so I have to consider what happens
when they a sure event is example
happening at a short time right and in
this case I have multiple frequencies
not just a one single frequency so if I
have mode or frequency let's look at the
simplest if I just have two frequency
what happens right let's say one
frequency is Omega 0 plus Delta Omega
and correspondingly I have K 0 plus
Delta K right
because it's nonlinear so I have Omega 0
minus Delta Omega and K their own master
ok so those are two different waves with
slightly different they all center
either Omega 0 but they are small small
spreading right dot Omega and Delta K
and now I have really what's propagating
are this similar density to wave I
generated and the superposition of these
two waves right so if I look at a
superimposed way-hey I'm assuming they
are same amplitude just to make a life
simpler and minus I Omega 0 plus Delta
Omega t minus k plus the other K X K 0
and plus the other frequency and we
vector is mass I Omega 0 Macedonia
t minus k0 masseteric hey X and I have
the superposition of this real signal
the propagating in the media because the
jet has two waves in the signal and when
I add this up you have a central
frequency Omega K 0 I can plot then I
have a plus term a minus term in the
exponent so you do your algebra what
your gather is to a cosine Delta Omega
times T Delta K times X and then
exponential minus I Omega 0 T minus K 0
X so this is the result will not have
two waves that with a small separation
in frequency and we vector and you look
at this now they what's propagating here
I have a high high a frequency Omega 0 T
0 central 1 here I have another cosine
that are modulate this frequency right
so what I really have is a cosine signal
that's a Delta Omega Delta K so which is
slower typically and then this is the
amplitude of the right so at the center
I have Omega 0 K 0 modulated so this is
the FM signal is a a.m. or FM AM signal
you modulate in the amplitude of the
central frequency right so what
this is a so now I have the outer
envelope who is cosine Omega t minus KX
now if you think about the what energy I
say the pointing vector for example when
I think about electromagnetic wave but I
pointing vector is the e cross H right
and of course I have one half real part
of that now if I have this charm inside
equals ash right yi has this term ih
complex conjugate also has this term but
as a plus you know that this term
actually to about we do equals H so what
is really then the energy is actually
the front term here so what energies are
propagating is like in this case is a
slower packet propagating that's a wave
packet and the speed of this propagation
now if I look at this factor there is DT
D DX DT so the DX DT is Delta Omega
Delta K so this is actually what are the
propagation this wave packet is
propagating at this speed new speed
there and this speed in the limit of
very low delta omega delta k i have a
derivative right so this is a equals D
Omega DK and this is my AG group
velocity that's why I'm doing the group
velocity and when I do transport I used
way the group velocity the phase
velocity is phase velocity is omega over
K that's this triangle here that's the
phase velocity and in fact if you go to
check at your density of states when you
calculate is explicit you're young your
phase velocity you want both phase
velocity and group velocity okay but see
well I do transfer that when I think
about how fast the particle or energy is
going from one place to other
there we packet and I should use the
group velocity for the actual transport
speed and when I calculated this when I
convert this modes into this out through
the top states I should be careful as
some is the group velocity some is the
phase velocity and of course this is
only one direction and in three
direction in general so the group
velocity is a vector alright so this one
is for example if you do Cartesian
coordinate for K space is d Omega DK x
KX and D Omega DK y KY and D Omega DK is
a hazy so that's a general group
velocity and with that you can say now
if I go back to photons right and this
is the when I have the up your foe la ku
Steve :
right if you look at the group velocity
very small K this was the tangent here
is much larger then at the end of the K
zone boundary a tippler a is zero flat
so here is a speed of sound that you can
measure and here at some boundary a
group velocity v-0 so the acoustic
fallen group as it is changing
up your phone on the group velocity is
the tipping are very small even though
the phase velocity is very high Omega or
okay right well Mia is very large phase
velocity is large is large but group
velocity is very small and when you do
specific here it turns out the simple
Debye model or plus Einstein model is
fine but when you do transport this
velocity becomes more important so you
and though most models in new teacher
and in fact 90% of those papers you
check nowadays we typically simplifies
the by model it's the model we do heat
transfer a thermal connectivity but that
were typically two very different
results from reality because of the use
of the group velocity do a bit major
factor and this is the case of photon
and you can also so you think about
electron so for example I have electron
this is the energy this is okay that's
typical dispersion right and so are they
Center the minimum the group velocity is
zero this is because it's a probiotic
man right we said some electron in fact
in the problem in the midterm with this
some of this graphene they have but I
say dinner dispersion so at the K equals
zero the velocity is not zero but say
most time this is zero and velocity zero
so you if you think about the parabolic
band the group velocity right let's say
here KX is d Omega Omega is e over H pop
right that's Omega and D K X let's say
in the X direction and Yi if it's a
parabola band right
then you can say is h-bar K X over m so
this is P or M momentum divided the mass
that's consistent when we have in the
classical limit right so but on the
other hand if you say okay my ash e
equals H bar square K square over 2m
right so this is this is cheaper
parabolic a bad right and if I just use
the phase velocity off of this by I will
not gather the same as a group velocity
so group velocity is like my speed of
the free particle here because the phase
velocity you get a factor of two
difference but there are some
interesting case this is actually we
always say most of time that group
velocity is the way you calculate
transport there are trickier cases where
this become very this is actually not
right and if you check a literature or
probably last 50 years there are
actually discussion people will say well
some of this would go over the speed of
light right and in fact if you look at
the object constant we know that the
speed of light in a media is say 0 or M
right this is a phase velocity and it
turns out that you check the opera
constant of some media refractive index
real part this is the end this is the
Omega and inside some of them you got
zero you may have this is a 1 this is a
1 and the sum of this or me I look like
this refractive index real part so what
happens is here of course n is less than
1 so the phase velocity is much larger
than the speed of night but that's fine
say okay that's not the energy velocity
okay so you're still comfortable but
then if you go to take the derivative of
DN T say Omega you find that either even
the group velocity in this region could
be larger than one so you ran into our
violating Einsteins relativity principle
right and the reason there is that in
this case is actually not at the group
velocity that's the energy velocity
right and when this varies very rapidly
when this Omega zero or one Guevara or
Tabor is very rapidly and those
quantities is a strong function of Omega
K so you cannot pull out and do the what
with the analysis we do here so in that
case there is actually a so called the
signal velocity and a few you about 15
more remember probably yeah in the line
is there actually some sensation people
actually measure some of this signal
first to reach beyond the speed of light
anything beyond a stupid light Einstein
still valid right then say it so they
party the people who do the work will
say this is a lot of violation of
Einstein the relativity principle
because this is only the first part of
the signal the signal has not a complete
gone through it so your night you and oh
you you the front of that signal comes
but not all the information has to be
transferred so you're still not
violating the Einstein principle but
there are no audible news coverage or
time and so anyway
that's a sidetrack so that's why when we
do the calculation we will use the group
velocity so we have now I say answer to
pretty much all the questions I say how
fast that's group velocity say how many
right density of states and then each
state the distribution function right
and so with those say how far and in in
certain case those transmission tells us
tells us how much is going forward how
much backward and what we're going next
is here all the discussion is based on
the wave picture right but if you think
about your mechanical engineer long of
the equations you learned so far was
based on weak picture right how we go
from that wave to completely ignore the
way to treat them as partners so this is
another very very deep subject okay and
it's a one that people still doing a lot
of research on and I'm going to give you
my best shot at making transition of
forgetting those face of the wave and go
into the particle right so one of the my
objective is for you to say when you
should get worried right either which
two men you should be varied about wavy
facts cross your side effect and you
feel comfortable using your continuum
equations so that's one of the my
objective and now I'm shooting at after
a group velocity is a wave two particle
transition and this is the where I say
were still of examine even now writing
trying to write a good paper product and
there are many is a
concept that I learned before I had to
revise it constantly it's a picture that
hard to actually clarify and a lot of
research being done in different aspects
of this so the question is when why deal
was a wave
I saw a Maxwell equation I saw a crystal
wave equation and the question is a 1
can i neglect him right when I do the
wave I carry the face that complex
lumber there right is it gives me a lot
of variation which is good if you want a
variation that's most beautiful ok you
can but say 1 connect back there right
let me go back to what I mentioned
before the in reality you do not have
extended the wave you have a packet
right so in material right I have an
atom jiggling locally emit a time signal
of house right and there could be a
pulse length or over certain amount of
time right and also over certain space
your extent so this is a this is of a
packet right composed a lot of full
frequencies and if let's say there is
the frequency spread is Delta Nu and in
optics there is definition of coherence
and in fact I say Kohana is a very
extensive discard disgusting optics
books if you want to understand
concurrence you should read that and
there is a quantum coherence there's
classical coherence and there's spatial
coherence there's time coherence ok and
here I'm given this simple it's the time
two horns so if I have a wave packet
that has the NS a frequency spread then
there is also corresponding space spread
because they have propagating different
velocity so this space spread is
coherence this is of the order of Delta
C Delta Nu the speed of light divided by
the spread right that gives you the lens
scale so so yeah physically this way
pocket also cover some lens skill and
the space coherence is at two points
whether the we packet are correlated a
la right and typically with a random
thermal source for example I have
vibration atomic vibration here another
place I'll typically just ignore this
spatial coherence the two vibrations are
spiritually uncorrelated but there are
other cases where they are actually
correlated okay but say what I actually
had a lot of work this time stranding
myself over this process many years but
first let's say I am mention if you
recall if I have way pocket if I have
perfectly interface right and it comes
to the interface and the sum of this
what transmit it and you can see that is
still the same packet right transmit it
reflect it they some of this is
reflected
right so I that zero sickness at the
interface the reflection and incoming
are spatially so they correlated this is
the same way packet so you have to if
it's a perfect interface there you have
to use your rate wave mechanics to deal
with this away right so that's a single
simple interface then I what about the
film right so if I think about the film
of thickness D and my wave packet comes
in right the I'm looking at that reason
the same because if they are the same if
the overlap specially you have to
include that face addition they
interfere with each other if they come
from different way packet they are not
correlated because the one that they
emitted say in the next hand step may
not be corridor is the one that emitted
at the previous time step right so two
different we packet I don't hear I'm
considered the one that somewhere coming
from a source propagating inside the
film and now reflect it so whether I
consider interference a lot then this is
the same wave packet may be a different
amplitude but they come from the same
part right so if this spatially overlap
you have to include the you the furnace
you have to use the wave superposition
that we did before so so one of the
criteria is so if D is a much larger
than coherence if this is very large the
same we pack of course at the interface
I have to use that for a nail formula
which is a wave result but
once they away from in the frame most of
the region in the film like a window
this packet will not overlap so you can
just trace them as a particle
trajectories forget about the face
because you do face so you'll get the
same result
right so that's a one sinner in fact I
thought I saw was the Moses in your room
I was the first paper when I was a
student I wrote a PhD student I wrote
was on this problem and I saw that that
will answer the way particle transition
and in fact in optics so there are two
ways one is the transfer matrix to
calculate reflectance the other is just
completely ignore the interference and
the to retrace in energy bouncing back
and forth right but you look at the
formula it's very different so I
actually was just cook up of formula and
I mean say then my eyes are say oh you
should look at theory so I went to check
out it turns out there is all this
optical harness theory and I use the
theory and I say that's the transition
so this is where the demarcation come
from film is the sake you neglect si in
France film the thin you don't need that
inference simple very logical but then
years later I realized this is a problem
matter people probably know this very
well but the problem is if I have a
black body which has a spread and in
fact that you can calculate the
effective bread spread your black body
has a right it's a pig right you see 0
to infinitive frequency but you can
calculate effective bandwidth of that 0
to infinite because it Peaks around
Winston all right so I see when I
calculate the multi-layer structure
particularly superlatives we mentioned
before Bragg reflector right
Bragg reflector is the one-to-one to
repeating structure no
and turns out that I you really don't
get this result they see the limited
unions very sick you still get your
weave result you can never get the
result of where you neglect a completely
the interference effect so it's all
about this and now the physical
explanation is again is the same prior
says the way packet came from the same
parent the actual overlap why if you say
okay here I have a packet comes in and
they go into the first layer and that
packet and reflect what's refract to the
second layer reflect the ones right this
is this from the splitter from the same
parent packet there of course because of
the time delay I don't have an overlap
between this one and this one right
because this one already this one travel
longer time so when this way packet
coming into this layer it's already this
one already gone off however but this
one had a lot of reflection here another
reflection back and that's coming from
the same parent and this tool can
spatially overlap and here's you and
though you have a thick one they can
still interfere with each other so your
structure actually gave this packet a
cohort so you cannot completely just use
the governor this simple cohorts lens to
neglect the wavy effect okay so that's a
say in lesson learned in optics and the
next lesson is the Fallen scatter which
will dive in in the next lecture
and fallen fallen scattering so we're
going to have the largest vibration and
they are typically three full-on
interaction process so in this case what
I have is inelastic scattering so now I
have to look at the scatter so elastic
scattering is when I have one for Omega
one two photon comes in and they
interact the forms are falling and the
energy of the third is the sum of women
go and plus Omega 2 right those kind of
processor pops up randomly in the solid
because fallen propagate anywhere they
are not fixed right so no scattering
those processes are usually considered
as a face destroying so in elastic
scattering typically if you process is
dominated by inelastic scattering and
that gives you the let's say the mean
free path the distance between the
scattering event right
and of course say the scattering self
may involve in our face they see at this
face superposition but between one point
to the other the way when they scatter
it propagates as a packet the Lexi
instant is scattered to another
direction as a completely different wave
packet because they lose their prior to
informations at random so in this case I
can consider the waves I can forget
about the
superposition of waves between different
scatter waves so tray them as particles
uncorrelated particles so inelastic
scattering is typically you can treat as
a si particle if this process dominant
but there's another process for example
if I have C solid or impurity atom in
the material and the wave come seeing
whether it's the electron wave will fall
on where they come seen either one
omigod it goes out and another one the
same Omega they just changed the ration
right this is a light for example
typically when you have dusting in the
sky the light comes in the diffract to
your eye this kind of process the
particle position is fixed right
but the scattering direction could be
depends on the solution you have to
solve the Maxwell equation for that
problems classic called me theory or you
solve the the electron atom of all this
problems so because this guy is a fixed
so the scatter one actually have a fixed
phase relation different direction
you have different fixed wave so this
are the elastic scatter and typically
elastic scattering really does not
destroy a face right because say this
position is affects it just got the flag
of different direction maybe a different
face but this one this one has a fixed
phase relationship so then the question
is do i tray them as particle see for
this wise dominant turns out here you
got really complicated possibilities for
example you have we have many particles
and and you can have a way
come seen as guess as a scatter into
here and scatter into here and you could
also have wave scatter back along the
same path and completely cancel the
incoming Li so those kind of a wave
superposition is called the localization
so if it's a less elastic scatter you
can have localization and you could also
have where because at least the each one
you can have a complete pattern of
scattering even though the fix is
different directions affixed with the
recording to the incoming one but will
you consider many of them specially they
are random enough you actually clean
neglect neglect those phase
superposition so in that case you can go
again into the particle picture you
finish localization you can op but in
the other limit you can neglect the face
you just treat them as particles okay
here you was I when I can do it I can't
tell you it's very complicated
okay and that the idea of who if you
actually read it because you know we
discussed several times the photonic
crystal okay and the photonic crystal
that concept the name was coined by yob
lavash but in the same year there was
another paper starting the same
phenomenon that's by john Sanji and he
was studying the same structure and he
wants to look either when the wave get
localized see there are complete
different angle looking the same problem
so yeah a photonic crystal is actually a
temporary accredit to two people job low
vision and johnson gia okay
so you look at a different literature it
turns out in optics people talk a lot on
cohorts and see a person electron
transport a lot of people also talk
cohorts and one of the biggest problem
with the quantum computing is how you
can keep the wave phase you don't lose
the face you lose the face of your
superposition of waves is gunk right so
you maintain the face cohorts time and
electric if you read the literature
there are many different names for
example there is this I think it's a
very solid estimate the different length
scales and of course their diffusion and
all those so talking about those
transition picture very very complicated
and we have been studying heat
conduction in superlatives and recently
which we think we have really found the
evidence there there is a phase
coherence contribution to thermal
conductivity and there is another very
mysterious result on thermal
conductivity of nano wires where there
are some rough non aware people
reporting way below what are they
classical sighs if I could predict and
not a paper being reading and some
speculation whether localization is the
reason or not
but there's really no strong proof so
doing theory doing experiment and in all
those regime are very difficult okay so
given what I said so you see this is the
area needs more research you might be
interested in doing it but now I'm
making the transition I say
I'm jammed jumping from the case where I
consider the face of the wave as I do in
this chapter to the case in the next
I'm going to trade all those energy
carriers as a particles I completely
ignore the face right this is a
different level of corn inanity remember
when we talked about Einstein wave
particle duality is a waves is both wave
and particle it has a momentum it has a
face
right but what I'm saying is that the
I'm migrating into a classical regime
where I completely drop out they face
information and look at trajectory of
those particles so there this is where
we're migrating to the next chapter and
chapter 6 so chapter 6 they will start
talking about that they they transport
by particles okay and let's start always
a general equation in this case lo vuoi
equation solovar equation describe the
sea partner in your system how they move
and it's very general because let's
suppose I have n particles in the system
and let's suppose the each particle has
say 2m each particle to M degree of
freedom
and this degrees of freedom represent
for example if I have X Y Z in Cartesian
coordinate translation or degree of
freedom
I will also have we actually very busy
right so I have momentum
I have coordinate space coordinate or if
you think of an angular Theta Phi you
have angular momentum so 2 m is if I
have our right see our the ice particle
I have R 1 2 R say I am this is space
degree of Moon see I see freedom and
correspondingly I have pi-1 and pi2 I
have 2 m right I'm going to use a
location ok my total number of a degree
of the freedom is 2 n equals to M times
n that's total number of degree of
freedom see I have n particle in the
system 10 to the 23rd of gara constant
right if you each partner is a
monoatomic it's only doing translation
so I have six because the M is 3 for X Y
Z and the way X we have is a gives me 6
so each partner I need six and six times
n gives me a total number of degree of
freedom but I have say I use a
generalized so if I general this one I
have two n say are N and P and this are
my generalized coordinate right so if we
if we capital n is one I say a bank
Avogadro constant this is a six because
I just explained six n is my say divided
by 2 is 3 and is
is a safe space coordinate and momentum
coordinated right so this is a huge
number
high order space right and at each point
if I have one point in that space I know
the whole system because I know every
particles position and momentum right so
now you have to generalize your 3d to n
dimension to n dimension and nobody can
draw that of course and this is my face
space so this one forms my face space
okay
and now if you recall in Chapter four
when we discuss the generalized theory
of survey statistics we mention now that
I say you don't need to really lock the
test it as you say right but I did
mention the in-sample concept right so
example is if I take a system either
isolated and all constant temperature or
constant temperature and constant number
plus a constant chemical potential right
so I take each quantum state rather than
do time averaging I do each quantum
state is C see example it's a one system
in my example right so each quantum
state now has a one set of four are NPN
right because I know the position and
now the momentum of all the particles so
one side of our NPN and if I have many
quantum states
I have many point that many points in my
face space right so in my face
now I can't draw it so I'm going to
simplify my RN my PN right I have in
this example each point represent a
quantum state of the example in the
phase space okay and of course now I
have many many particles in my face
space so I can do density I can do
probability density and my so that I
introduce the particle distribution
function so the F n so this one is the
number of particles and T and R and P
and right this is the N particle capital
n I have Empire in the system
distribution function and what it means
is if I know this distribution function
I multiply by the volume of this face
space in this near that point R NP n and
that gives me the Lambor of systems
systems in the in-sample having the
coordinator arm here at Mt
right so this one is my n particle
distribution function
okay so as my time evolves right now I'm
doing going to mix my time within sample
as time evolves the system state change
right
that means each of the inside ball will
also evolved in time each of the system
in the example right but say because
each system started with a quantum state
as the time goes on the two system can
never have the same quantum state right
otherwise you go back you will see if
the star is the same you go back a walk
time reversal you will be the same so so
what does that mean is this each point
as time goes you form a streamline now
you can think about fluid mechanics
right you form a stream line and this
stream line do not intersect
it's actually an incompressible flow in
this n dimensional phase space - n
dimensional phase space okay if it's an
incompressible flow and the particle is
conserved you can write actually an
equation of motion for this effort right
and everything is incompressible and if
you think about this is a if you
construe 2005/2006 it derived actually
they like a mature derivative all those
stuff so you can do actually
differential volume you see what I'm
seeing what goes out will come see what
goes out right and because
incompressible so at the end what we
have is the equation for this
distribution function
what I have is DF and DT this is time
and and then Sigma I equals to 1/2 and
that see our time derivative so I will
do a dot this dr/dt because I'm doing
time evolution and D F and D are and
plus I equals 1 to N and P time
derivative No so I should not do I this
is I this is not n because I'm doing
summation over I the P D F n D P I and
this is an incompressible flow and this
is essentially the Louisville equation
ok nobody stops it it's heartless all
right you have if you think about degree
of freedom is 2 n I'm gonna Zadro
Avogadro constant right but it's the
start and from here the physics branch
into two directions and one is they from
here Y is the Boltzmann equation
okay and boards my how to go from a low
voice equation to boards my equation
their books a whole book devoted to it
many many layers of distress a
approximation okay
and worse than the three chapters
discussing boards my equation and then
there is also the nini response theory
and if you if you have enough time
chapter line chapter 10 chapter lines
without start of a linear response
theory boards man of course this a is a
way earlier than Einstein and Einsteins
one of iceland's motivation in his PhD
thesis was his PhD thesis was on
Brownian motion one is to use Brownian
motion determine the atomic molecular
size one of this multi-mission but
another motivation is that the Boltzmann
equation is the only applicable to
dilute gas okay so I said I can trade
parallel electron photon photon
molecules but I can treat the liquid
right liquid is not a tyloo gas and what
Einstein started is trying to develop a
parallel theory to Boardman so he's
actually he laid they say the starting
point of this branch linear response
theory
and if you do molecular dynamics this is
a actuary they say you start from noble
equation
you don't write was simplified you swap
each atom you know a computer now
becomes more powerful so you can
actually do your impart glory problem if
you call em a to say you have to know
you need to know the linear response
theory that's the foundation for all the
analysis and in fact that it's conceptor
is very easy equal to do F equals MA but
how to get into the understanding the
where that's this theoretical foundation
ok so this is a day
Louisville equation and also there is a
very interesting if you go to for
example talk about those how they
entropy right you will surely come out
of those equations it's still very
heavily debated right because of those
most of this equation is a time reversal
you put a negative time and goes back to
original point but entropy is not a time
reversal it's time you increasing okay
so that's a that's another say still
very confusing point so let's go from
here to boards my equation we're not
going to finish this and poured my
equation is a tremendous simplification
and here we have in the
if they say logo equation I have an
unparticle distribution function a is
Avogadro's constant what birds my
equation does is a one part of your
distribution function from ten to twenty
third down to what that's a
simplification that's in many order
that's why I say lot of books are
annoyed right and the Boltzmann equation
is defining the one particle or no is a
ft r and p right any particle that has a
location R NP or maybe I can just
arrived this is a let me start with one
particle rather than the T R 1 T 1 right
and then I generalize R 1 P 1 because
it's just any particle so I RP and what
it has is the average of the over all
other if I have ten to twenty third
party girl so I average over the origins
of 23rd months one particles so what I
have what I have is in definition is
that I have the n bacteria and mass 1
factorial and that is averaging over the
all the other particles right so this is
a F and but then I'm integrating our TR
2 to D our N and D P 2 D G and you can
say I'm averaging all the rest of the
particle I say this is my one part of
your distribution function okay and
because of this now this particle other
than a system in the assemble right in
level interact with other systems in the
same example it's parallel
incompressible
non-interacting that's Louisville now
I'm one particle in the system in this
system you will interact it will collide
with other particles right so if you do
your integration averaging over the
Louisville serum you get all the plot of
the other particle that's the one part
of your interacting with the other so
what I have in the equation is the
Boltzmann equation is d F now I do this
F in general I'll say DF DT I don't
write one anymore dr/dt and the other
are f right
this R is generalized coordinate for one
particle and the deep sea generalized
momentum DT and the gradient with
respect to P F this is one particle
I'm averaging over other 23 particle ten
to twenty third party course the
averaging term is not zero and I'm put
in here right now just into a symbol
that's the interaction that's my
collision term of this particle with the
rest okay and this is a half way to the
boards by equation right so it's simply
from 10 to the 23rd of a huge number to
one part of your distribution function
and of course DP DT you can write F over
N that's a a and then this P could be
changing to velocity because I say
that's a derivative whether you're right
don't have way
F so if a dp/dt is then x because the N
right P is in the T in the denominator P
is MV so you can write the M 1 or M or
you can even write into the quantum form
K right P equals HK right so you will be
H bar times K now 1 or H bar because
this one equal also is in terms of K is
the 1 or H bar so there are different
ways to write this momentum term but the
most complicated is here the interaction
and I will discuss this in the next
lecture that's a very complex term but
what I want to drop to you is the
Boltzmann equation is based on if you
know one part of your distribution the
assumption if you know one part of
distribution function you know they all
the other particle distribution function
and the reason is this molecular kills
Piazza assumption right so molecular
kills
and just to say the partners do not
really interfere with each other this
scatter they interact but I say you know
the distribution function a one part of
our Dane you know they're all the end
particles so this is an unparticle
distribution function T are n PN that's
what we wanna write in the lower
equation and molecular chaos is just so
this is the F 1 T R 1 T 1 times write
the same T 1 T R and P n so if I now
this distribution function as general
function of space momentum I know they
all they say n particle distribution
function so this is the it's a
independent so you do have collision but
after collision they forget the where
they came from the loss of memory and
some electric health that's a
fundamental in how you can get from the
Louisville theory equation to the boards
my equation okay and just what my
commander is a for example boards my
equation when you have a dense fluids it
doesn't apply so what the people had
tried to modify is actually to to
particular and consider final size of
the molecule there's another equation
called an Scott which is a two particle
distribution but the because equation
became very hard to handle
not many people ever solved it and so
that's a sense of 60s more effort we're
actually going into the linear response
because the computer become available
people can do computational analysis and
go response here okay